happy to have back here on this program
um obviously we will talk
about the super bowl with michelle
tafoyo who had both the chiefs and bucks
in front of her
in her job uh for sunday night football
and football night in america on nbc but
uh her new podcast the deep dive
uh last time uh michelle was on we
talked about the deep dive she had in
john
gruden but her deep dive and sports
uncovered is my favorite kobe story and
here on the one-year anniversary of
kobe's untimely demise with his daughter
and seven others in a helicopter crash
here in southern california
michelle tafoya back here on the show
how are you michelle
i am good rich how you doing better for
talking to you appreciate you uh taking
the time here
um did you uh have this subject matter
in mind for today
michelle for your podcast well we
certainly
wanted the podcast to be available right
around this time
um for sure it's it's in some ways it's
hard to believe it's been a year
and then in some ways it's hard to
believe it's only been a year you know
what i mean it's been such a strange
year and everyone loves to say how much
we've hated
2020 and i think this was one of the
first
horrible things that happened in 2020
was kobe's death and
uh everyone remembers where they were
and when they found out
and um you know it's still it's still
sometimes hard to believe rich
you look at photos of him and it's
just so young it's still sometimes hard
to believe
so um let's get into uh who people can
hear on this pod
uh and you had everybody tell you your
favorite kobe story i'll give you the
floor
and what you what you yeah i mean it's a
lot of different people
from sue bird to um
to oh my gosh the names are so many it's
hard to pick usain bolt and
his uh recollection of meeting kobe and
how kobe influenced his view of having a
little girl
having a baby girl there are all kinds
of
interesting anecdotes that aren't the
big
you know publicized stories about kobe
bryant
they're these little kind of side tales
that make you go
wow and i think it just really fleshes
out
a lot more of his personality who he was
the legacy he left behind
the people he influenced the things that
he did
and um it teaches you a little bit more
about his evolution you learn a little
bit more about his evolution as a person
as a human not just as a player and
um that's what that's what i loved about
having these different people on recall
you know
first guy we talked to was his high
school basketball coach and how
that whole his coming into the program
and into the full changed
everything there um really and it
you know has still left a legacy so
there's just a lot
of detail when you've lived a life that
rich and that thorough um
and even though it was cut short there
are a lot of stories that you leave
behind and not all of them get told but
in this
in this podcast some really interesting
tales get told
michelle tafoya nbc sports but also
uh back uh just about a decade ago a
decade plus
ago um sidelined reporter for the nba on
abc
and espn what's your favorite kobe story
from your tenure
doing that gig oh my gosh it has to be a
christmas day
one and i think it was the first time al
michaels and i
ever worked together was a christmas day
game of the lakers and they went into
halftime trailing
and um you know i went back by the
locker rooms
and waited to see and to talk to coaches
and to see what was going to happen when
these guys came out of the locker room
and kobe came out
and his little girl was waiting for him
and um she was in her christmas dress
this little red dress
and he picked her up and like his face
changed you know he was not happy with
the way they were playing
and his face just changed and his tone
of voice changed and he picked her up
and she said something to him and he
kissed her and he put her down and they
went
out and of course won the game and i
just remember
seeing that human side of him that you
know i've never seen him with his
children before with any of us
you know i think this was his oldest so
it was just you know okay wow
um and it was just such a precious
moment and so
that one always stands out to me
you know in in in the wake of his
passing and the outpouring of emotion
and shock um
came the remarkable stories
that kobe didn't want told
because of what he was doing behind the
scenes to either
pay it forward um be there for people
who
were ill or at the time
just being a counselor to people or
a sounding board or a mentor in a way
that a lot of folks did not think was
possible for him because
he had such an outward mamba mentality i
mean the video of him
being you know um downright uh
angry at his teammates towards the end
of his tenure there right or there was
of
yeah there was also an instagram post
that went viral of him
uh being a coach to his daughter and her
teammates
and they all looked miserable right and
we all assumed that
that kobe was just pulling a mamba
mentality on these poor girls and they
were not
happy to do what they were doing with
them and that couldn't have been further
from the truth at the time it was just a
picture that told
uh a terrible thousand-word story right
there that was inaccurate
that that to me is you know what i'm
thinking about today was that outpouring
of emotion all these stories that came
out you did not know was happening
yeah yeah i i just remember where i was
when i found out my son actually came
running down to tell me
and i like everyone else i didn't
believe him
i figured you know he was on the gram or
on snapchat and got some bad information
and you know when a a little kid is kind
of
excited and nervous and they kind of go
on
you won't believe this and there's a
nervous laughter that comes along with
with you know a 13 year old kid
and um and i said to him you're you're
lying
so or you've got some bad information
and
uh then we went up but it got me from
what i was doing and we went and we
searched and we
thought and i was just you know it's a
it's a feeling of disbelief he was so
young and
and the whole the whole circumstance of
it with these other wonderful people and
young women and all of it it's just
i was so looking forward to seeing
kobe's next chapter
and you know so that is why we still
mourn i think
because there was so much he was about
to do
and and also because we really did watch
him grow up where
he was he was a player for a long time
from a young age
and again sports uncovered is uh
michelle tafoy's podcast and she
interviewed
uh so many bold-faced name individuals
with their favorite kobe story you could
get it where every single
podcast is acquired and you could
subscribe for free and we suggest
everybody do that um i'd be remiss if i
did not ask you your thoughts of the
match-up of super bowl 55
this is these are the football gods
getting together saying all right
the pandemic year is kind of stunk but
let's get brady let's get the goat
versus the kid before we go out of dodge
here right i mean this is amazing
don't you think you know i think it is
and
uh and i'm a little jealous it's not on
nbc no
cbs is gonna have a great time with this
one pandemic or not this is
this is the stuff that yeah football
dreams are made of
um and quite frankly i i wasn't sure
tom was going to get back there it you
doubt him at your peril
you know you just you don't doubt him i
think there are
so many story lines here and it starts
with the age gap between the two
quarterbacks and the
the different styles and the fact that
it's so hard to turn away from the tv
when either of them
is playing and uh and there are going to
be so many
other stories to be told about you know
other players
immediately i think kansas city's
offense is just such a thing of great
potency how is anyone gonna you know
slow this thing down
uh you can in the beginning and we've
seen kansas city time and time again
you know be down three seven nine points
whatever and then suddenly
boom the floodgates open we'll see if
that happens
um and then if tom wins or if tom
doesn't win
is this the last one you know we're all
to be asking that question
too so it's a great matchup i i really
am excited about it
so i mean and this i think can sum it up
about brady as well
you know um as they're going against
mahomes which is going to be what a heck
of a match up that is right but
the fact is that the last game that you
and the nbc crew
had of brady's this year um
regular season is is the
the blowout loss to the saints and if
i i'm unless i'm mistaken um that the
blowout lost the saints if i'd come up
to you
michelle after the game say guess what
brady and the bucks are going to be here
anyway against the chiefs for the super
bowl
your initial reaction might have been
like no way come on and then after a few
seconds go well
that's brady i mean it's entirely
possible
right i mean the crazy thing is and
you're right after that game after that
loss
uh to the saints i thought okay you know
what
we thought this was gonna be really cool
and we thought they were gonna be really
good down here in tampa maybe we were
wrong
um but then they kind of started to get
it together you know as brady
are want to do i mean we've seen that
with the patriots time and time again
with brady there
it's just crazy it's just um and you
know for all those people
rich who are sick and tired of seeing
brady in in the
in the super bowl think of it this way
we're really watching
something we're not going to see for a
long long long time again
if ever you know it's like watching
tiger woods golf as much as you hate
seeing him win or whatever for those who
do
you're watching greatness of a different
level and so try to appreciate the fact
that you get to witness it
and years from now you'll get to tell
everyone about it the way that they told
you that they watched mickey mantle and
all the rest of these greats you know so
i
i it is really truly something and in
terms of that you know we may never see
it again
um that obviously based on looking at
the numbers that brady has
um you know would normally go without
saying
and the only way that somebody could
match him or catch him
is if they start hot right they start
hot and they win early
and they have a coach that's not going
to go anywhere right
do you see where i'm going with this
right and and i'm i
i you know i think brady would be
thinking three-dimensionally
four-dimensionally
as thinking basically one way to
actually
derail that is to beat this kid and this
coach right now as opposed to letting
him go back-to-back he would have two in
his first four years brady didn't get
his second
until you know um his fourth year as
well
and you know and then go back to back
four and five this kid would go
three and four back to back he would
actually might even be ahead of the pace
when you think about it yeah even with
both of them having missed their first
year
too so i'm wondering if brady will be
sitting there thinking you know what
this is as if he needs any more reasons
to win a super bowl
but i mean i had that thought when they
were playing the packers i had that
thought of
him just deciding no aaron i know a lot
of people were talking about you as mvp
you know i get it and you're really
really good but
we're gonna get this done it's hard to
know what's in brady's brain
it really is is how macro is he thinking
or how micro is he thinking and it
really does make a difference because
to me if you're thinking micro you're
thinking on this play on this down
what am i doing what do i see and if i
stack those up
i'm going to be okay on the macro level
you know i'm creating a legacy here
dammit and
you know aaron's not keeping me from
another super bowl
so it's really it is interesting to
think about and
you're right i mean this chief team
looks like one for the ages
and we're all we're at the very
beginning as you said
and uh but um that's what
you're right that's just one more level
of looking at this matchup that makes it
so
interesting i think though you're right
though at the very end of it he's
sitting there thinking okay
you know um frank clark is another
michigan man who's already said i'm
going to see
he's going to see my ass on on two
sundays from now
and you know tyron matthew is just next
level
excellent and so on and so forth i think
that that's he just keeps it that micro
and then just makes the throws he makes
the throws and he sees it and he he
performs in such a way at such a level
that is so unique and he just guns for
everybody and if he does it again
how many times have we said this if he
does it this time it's the most amazing
thing but this one is
uh 43 years of age in his his new team
in his first year in a new team in a
pandemic after doing it
one way for 20 years you know in his own
in his own home stadium
completing a run uh where he would get
brees
rogers and mahomes back to back to back
and if you want to throw a cherry on top
throw taylor heineken on top you know i
mean it's really um
yeah and like you said and make the
history of not only being the first team
to host
in their own stadium but then winning
there hello i mean that would be the
perfect way to end it
you just you shake your head and go why
you know why am i even thinking about
this but
uh all good things must come to an end
you keep wondering when it's going to be
but my gosh would that be
a walk into the sunset michelle thanks
for the call look forward to everybody
taking in your uh your podcast here on
this uh solemn day
uh and always appreciate the call you
take care of yourself thanks for the
call
thanks so much rich all the best that's
michelle tafoya check out again her
sports uncovered pod
about everybody telling a favorite kobe
story about usain bolt
saying he helped me with being a girl
dad usain bolt by the way
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here